do you have any idea who I am some rich
guy called you on the phone I want you
to speak with you about what you hope to
achieve what do you hope to achieve mark
want to be the best in the world good as
a key for you also big house is off
limits okay coach DuPont has a vision he
would like foxcatcher to be the official
training site for the national team
what's he at all this what are you
thinking this is it this is all that
we've that we've ever wanted mark you
have been living in your brother's
shadow your entire life it's your time
now promising out of you everything I I
am leading men and I am giving America
hope I spent my lifetime looking poor
father and I found one in John du Pont
it doesn't matter the sport of wrestling
has a low sport and I don't like to see
you being no wiser nobody in the gem
yeah no I give ungrateful ape mark mark
mark easy good
yeah I always need your help I tell
what's going on with you into pump hey
what'd I just say
the father
coaches a mentor
great power
mark